in this morning's eye on money we're
watching the stock markets after
yesterday's biggest drop since may the s
p 500 lost 75 points 1.7 percent the dow
and nasdaq also had big losses ahead of
a two-day federal reserve meeting that
starts today cbs news business analyst
joe schlesinger is with us today jill
what is going on what spurred the mass
sell-off now i don't want to freak
everyone out but some are calling this
china's lehman brothers moment
and this is what's going on you don't
want to scare people but i don't know
because i don't want you to read about
it and then get scared so let's put some
context into this there is a big
property company in china called
evergrand used borrowed money to expand
built a lot of residential units and
there's been a housing boom in china
chinese regulators have cracked down on
some of these practices said don't use
so much borrowed money company starts
going south and now with all this
borrowed money due to be paid back there
is a worry
that this company's problems this
bankruptcy that's looming could spread
in china could spread to the whole
chinese economy could spread around the
world that contagion fear is what
triggered yesterday's sell-off now after
a drop like this there's two ways to
look at it um there's panic right let's
get rid of everything and then there's
like it's like a scene out of 300
leonidas saying this is where we hold
what would you recommend well uh
somewhere in between
so
what i think is interesting is yesterday
large investment firms took the
opportunity to look at what they were
holding and saying wow maybe we got too
much risk in these portfolios we saw a
lot of big investors selling now think
about it coming into the session they
were up 18 on the year in the stock
market right that comes after last
year's 16 percent gain you see some
shakiness and you say let me take some
my risk off the table for us retirement
savers people who are plotting along
this is your moment you take a deep
cleansing breath you say let me stick to
my game plan let me not fall into the
trap of selling and after all you look
at where we are this morning and we see
a rebound is looming it doesn't mean
it's going to be perfect but if you
stick to your game plan i think you are
better rewarded in the long term it's
hard to take deep cleansing breaths when
you see the numbers drop it just is it's
just human nature
but you're always calm calm calm well
i want to say this i'm when you know
when i'm not calm when everyone is
jumping in and markets are making new
highs day after day there is just as
much risk when the market is up as when
it's down i think it's incumbent on us
as regular people who are investing for
the long term to remember why we're
investing have a game plan stick to the
game plan it will serve you well i
promise that's right you're the best
take a breath and you guys take a breath
and don't go anywhere thank you so much